Barbie is a film about being human about
becoming human Greta was the first
person and the only person we went to
because I love her as a writer as a
director you just hold on
Sublime I knew that she would be done
something that feels relevant and
current that's amazing great I love that
one she's an incredibly generous
brilliant person Greta's enthusiasm is
just completely contagious
I feel like we've always used dolls as a
way to kind of understand ourselves
through play
I thought well wouldn't it be wonderful
if she was allowed to be like us and to
be flawed and messy and not have to be
perfectly perfect
Greta's the best she's an incredible
director I think she's an auteur I don't
understand how a person has that clear
of a vision for every single detail of
the movie Greta's sense of humor and
intelligence and warmth and heart is in
everything goes to describe the script
as human emotion Express through dolls
and it was exactly that I wanted to
paint in big beautiful broad strokes and
build this crazy world and have it be
funny and real and relatable and I just
want people to feel joyful Barbie
[Music]